alireza you won your game but you came
into the studio and you were shaking
your head you seem a bit disappointed
did you feel like you could get more out
of today's rounds yeah i'm i'm very
disappointed with fabiano's game
i just
still i'm very upset about that game so
because i lost just against myself so
because he didn't do anything special of
course it was not needed so
what happened in the opening you play
that move at d4 after quite a serious
thing eight minutes yeah i had to take
on c6 first and then go d4 so that was
the theory but i just completely
messed up the
move order so yeah and that was after
that i didn't have any chance
yeah absolutely and then you immediately
bounced back big victory with the black
pieces what was the strategy going into
the last round did you want to keep the
tension in the position and play a long
game was that the strategy yeah i played
quarry gone um
normally it's a kind of risky line
nowadays
and white gets a very interesting game
but i thought it's at least something to
try i i was not in the mood to defend
just play for draw i wanted to have
chances also to play for win so
i thought i felt that that's a good
um that's a good
strategy but also i was lucky that he
was not in a good shape indeed for this
game he's throughout the game throughout
the tournament he's in a good shape but
here it did feel like he was putting
some pressure early on
but he was also burning through a lot of
his time yes he was thinking a lot my g5
is so unnecessary
13
13 g5 yes yeah g5 is just
um it's unnecessary i wanted to but you
played it fast yeah i played it very
quickly so but it's not a good choice i
think because i create a lot of
um weaknesses and h3 is a great move
now he just wants knight f3 yeah i think
c5 is only moved to go and keep going
i i didn't know what to do after knight
df3
cd4 g4
this is actually what like yasser was
recommending as well like g3 i need to
do it with something thanks yeah it was
thinking of this takes takes rook f2
bishop c5
queen e2 on decent game i'm okay wow
yeah somehow she takes b2 and then take
on f2 and yeah just because i felt that
this game maybe it's close to draw so i
wanted to keep the game going because he
didn't have enough time so yeah here i
knew that i'm maybe okay but
um
i still think that maybe my choice is
better practically absolutely you did
kept a lot of pieces and a lot of
tension still in the position and then
it felt like he went for this very
strange knight f e1 right were you
surprised by his decision yeah it's a
strange move but he has very little time
on the clock he has two three minutes so
it just feels like he's giving you
enough time to go h5 yes normally if you
don't have time with white you always
think about going f4 so
he wanted to go immediately knight d3 f4
so but he didn't have time to think
about h5 knight d3 g4 i think this is
what he missed
and he and now it gets very messy so he
has to go b4 it's a complete mass
position
and he went for g3
yeah and then i think i'm okay here
and here is very difficult for him to
play
practically because my knight is very
strong and he cannot challenge it so
yeah this is exactly what peter was
mentioning as well after e5 just from a
practical perspective especially with 15
seconds on the clock yeah it's not like
you're almost winning yeah it's almost
impossible to defend this over the board
with 10 seconds so
um yeah
yeah i was kind of
lucky that he had a little time to sink
in the middle game so
alireza is still the leader after uh two
days going into the final rapid uh day
how do you feel about your performance
so far yeah after the last round um i'm
i'm pretty happy but if the previous
game i still should work on it to forget
about it so um
yeah it's a it's an interesting
tournament a lot of ups and downs a lot
of people winning losing um we will see
what is going to happen the next few
days finally you're sporting this nba
shirt which one is your favorite thing
um
i always said chicago is very good
yeah
but there are many good teams now
thank you ali raza we'll see you
tomorrow